بحجم لا يتعدى نحو ملمتر واحد او اكبر
تصبح ملايين القطع من الحطام في الفضاء
بسرعات هائله وفي مدار ارضي منخفض تامل
شركه ناشئه في المملكه المتحده ان تساعد
اجهزه الكشف الجديده الخاصه بها في تتبع
بعض اخطر الحطام الفضائي والتي قد تعرض
الاقمار الاصطناعيه والمركبات الفضائيه لل
في حال حدوث
تصادم برنامج شركه اودن سبيس هو وضع خرائط
ل 99 في من الحطام الذي يعد صغيرا جدا
بالنسبه الى التكنولوجيا التي في الفضاء
انه ينتقل بسرعه كبيره بحيث يمثل خطرا على
الاقمار الاصطناعيه اذا لم توضع في المدار
الصحيح ينجم الحطام الفضائي عن انفجار
مركبات اطلاق مركبه فضائيه
او اجزاء منها او عندما تجري دول تجارب
صاروخيه لتدمير اقمارها الاصطناعيه
بالصواريخ ما قد يخلق سحبا من المواد
بعضها يمكن ان ينتقل بسرعه اكبر من
الرصاص الاجابه البسيطه هي نعم انها خطيره
وتزداد خطوره لذا فهي مشكله تصاعديه فال
الحطام يولد مزيدا من
الحطام تطلق الاف من الاقمار الاصطناعيه
التجاريه الى مدار الارض بوتيره قياسيه
مما يزيد من خطر الاصطدامات التي قد تؤدي
الى ظهور حقل من الحطام
الخطير تكرت شركه اودين سبيس نظام كشف
خفيف الوزن يمكنه التعرف على قطع النفايات
الصغيره التي يصل حجمها الى اقل من ملليتر
حتى عندما تتحرك بسرعه الاف الامتار في
الثانيه من خلال الاشارات
الصوتيه نطلق الواحا كهذه لتهبط على السطح
الخارجي للاقمار الاصطناعيه ثم يضرب
الحطام هذه الالواح ويخترقها ما يمكننا من
تحليل البيانات الخاصه بحجم قطعه الحطام
ومدى سرعه تحركها وفي اي اتجاه تتحرك
بتحليل الاشارات
الصوتيه صممت اللوحات لتوضع على متن
المركبات الفضائيه او الاقمار الاصطناعيه
الاخرى مما يؤدي الى انشاء شبكه من اجهزه
الاستشعار التي توفر صوره حقيقيه لبيئه
المذار